take me
it's Brittany
and I am back
in the form of a new company the Michael
Scott Paper Company
it's not gonna make this one
[Music]
well I uh guess it's time that I turn
over the keys to the famous Sebring
no thank you
it's a corporate least white you've
earned it no thanks
what
Style
but you said you liked it you've always
admired it and that was before I'm
thinking about getting something German
something with decent Gas Mileage Plus
the convertible is a ridiculous choice
for this climate
take it back
no
that's my car
what did you that's my car
yes
and it's weird because this is not like
me I am usually the guy they call in to
clean up the mess
like us today
I am going to have to call in myself
morning Michael hello
they took away my parking space but they
can't take away my pride
it turns out that Terry was already
suspicious because she had caught
Stanley and Cynthia a few months ago
so Stanley promised
that he would stop and he did end of
story well
not exactly uh Cynthia kept calling him
she would not stop calling him and she
was in love with them oh and get this
Cynthia also married so
throw out all the empties you don't want
to recycle them
um yes throw them away in the recycling
bin
do you want this
no
what about this bottle of power drink uh
what flavor blue the Blue's not a flavor
it says flavor blue blast oh blue blast
yes uh put that in the trunk and there
should be an unopened Arctic chill back
there I want that in the passengers cup
holder thank you
what's up whoa that's my truck on Noir
no this is Rite Aid night sweat no it is
a perfect smell alike I'm not paying for
the label right here give it well it's
empty no it's not there's some in the
straw
there now you may throw it out
wow
how many filet of fishes did you eat
that's over several months Ryan
rule number four in business image is
everything Andre Agassi
this car is an investment
right if I have to take out a client or
I'm seen around Scranton in it
I love it I love this car
do you like it
yeah this is going to be a very good
year very good
Jane is at home Jim is back
my protege Ryan is a corporate
good stuff
um Andy and Dwight are rocking the sales
team I feel very blessed
[Music]
sweet ride American made what happened
to the Sebring it is in the body shop
I had to have the den taken out of the
hood where I hit Meredith oh that's a
pain in the ass all right since I am the
boss I will drive as well who wants
shotgun you can't be serious you ran a
woman over this morning everyone inside
the car was fined Stanley
well what do you think it's been all
morning doing it it is really special
yeah but aren't you supposed to do that
to Ark no it's great well it's just a
really important day for me
well congrats thanks
[Applause]
proceed straight
well we're over six
Last Chance is the Elmhurst Country Club
other side of the lake on the Southeast
side I'll get it I really don't get it I
thought this would work
through everything I had at that guy
nothing that's how it goes sometimes you
know
you lose everything and everything falls
apart and eventually you die and no one
remembers you that is a very good point
make a right turn
wait wait wait no no no it means Bear
right
not there it said right it said take a
right no no no no no look it means go up
to the right Bear right over the bridge
and hook up with 307. make a right maybe
it's a shortcut Dwight it said go to the
right it can't mean that there's a link
it knows where it is going the machine
stop yelling at me
remain calm I have trained for this
okay
exit the window here we go make a U-turn
if possible
[Music]
are you okay swim for it
I got you I got you
guys
come on
come on come on
thank you
you sure you're okay
fine good
that is what's most important
did you get the rental insurance
because that is pretty important too at
a time like this
Ryan thinks that technology is the
answer well guess what I just drove my
car into a lake is it what I drove my
car into a lake so um I forgot to tell
you that I need the car tonight oh um
actually I need the car why for Improv
oh why don't you just pretend that you
have a car
good practice in case you ever do a
scene where you need to pretend you have
a car you used to have two cars traded
them in now we're down to one
good economic sense
although the new car's a Porsche for her
I want my old job back I want my old
parking space back I want a Sebring I
don't like them anymore
and I want Charles gone could we pull
over and put down the top my uh I gotta
feeling a little queasy I want it up my
hair well could we please pull over and
pull down the top I do not know I told
you I'm not putting this top down oh I'm
gonna puke all right but just a second
hold on
hmm
kind of shocks you got on this baby I
don't know regular normal ones
nothing fancy not my style
what are you doing
no Dwight it's 50 degrees outside please
but then no one can see us I just would
you put it up
okay fine just leave it down whiner
check it out
Terminator I do not understand what you
spend your money on you know you can
always refinance your mortgage
we had a 15-year on our beet Farm we
paid it off early yeah well you know
what nobody cares about your stupid beet
Farm
beats are the worst people love me
nobody likes beets everyone loves nobody
likes beets Dwight why don't you grow
something that everybody does like you
should grow candy
I'd love a piece of candy right now
not a Beat
this roof
so I need a little treat for the gang
something to win their affections back
why is that Michael
well I ran down Meredith in my car
no I was being negligent but she's in
the hospital she's fine recovering
nicely tiny little crack in her pelvis
but she will be out
yes it was on company property with
company property so Double Jeopardy we
are fine
I don't think you understand how
Jeopardy works